[Music]
hey guys it's katie and i'm here with my
husband chris hi and it's i'm up for a
new challenge this week very exciting it
involves chris he doesn't understand or
know why i have no idea what i'm doing
here i have no idea what's happening
it's great i thought i would be very fun
this week if i tried to recreate some
disney halloween treats
ones that you can get at disney world
disneyland do you want to see what they
are yes absolutely let me show you what
they are i love snacks
i know you do
that guy oh that guy
that one oh my god that looks fine and
that one oh my god these are gonna be
hard
what i have faith in you that at least
one of them will be close wow
the first treat i'm gonna make is the
mickey mummy macaron it's macaron right
macron macaron i hate this you guys tell
me in the comments how you pronounce it
macarons can be a little bit tricky to
make so i am actually using tasty's
recipe one that alexis made and did a
whole tasty 101 on so you guys should
check that out first we're just gonna
start with adding some powdered sugar
almond flour some salt we're putting
this in a food processor because we want
to grind down that almond flour with the
powdered sugar to a really really fine
powder now i'll take this and i'm going
to put it through a strainer and i would
do this in batches it's just a little
bit easier to manage and you won't get
it all over your table which i have
definitely done that looks good now i
have some room temperature eggs here
first we're going to do is separate the
egg whites from the egg yolks then add a
little salt and we'll mix this till it's
nice and foamy and get soft peaks once
we got our soft peaks we're going to add
in some sugar we're going to do this
slowly so we don't deflate our eggs and
let this mix until the eggs are shiny
and we get stiff peaks you know you're
there when you can put the bowl over
your head and nothing falls down then
we'll add a little bit of vanilla
extract
and i'm going to add some white gel food
coloring to make these super white
macarons now that our eggs are looking
real good we're going to slowly fold in
our dry ingredients we're looking to get
a ribbony texture where you can make it
eight without the batter breaking okay
i've got my batter in a piping bag and
i've got a sheet pan here here's the
moment of truth i'm gonna
pipe a mickey head which i think is just
a medium circle in two little circles it
should be fine he's so cute
he might be a little small let's try
again
i'm getting better with every mickey
next important thing to do is to smash
down
your pants
let these guys set for about 30 minutes
until i can run my hand over the top of
them and it's nice and smooth so these
guys are ready to go in the oven we're
gonna bake them at 300 for about 15 to
17 minutes okay we have our little
mickeys they look so cute i'm going to
transfer these guys to a cooling rack
and make the filling for the filling i'm
going to make life a little bit easier
on myself and used canned frosting then
i have some crushed chocolate cookie
sandwiches so basically i am making a
cookies and cream filling i'm going to
transfer this to a piping bag and then
we are almost there so i've melted some
white chocolate here and i am going to
be kind of criss crossing that over the
tops of these cookies to really make
them look like mummies
add
little
eyeballs oh my gosh they're so cute not
every cookie gets eyeballs every other
cookie will get eyeballs okay i'm gonna
let these fit until the white chocolate
sets then i'll add the filling
and these guys are done overall
so excited i cannot wait to show these
to chris they're my new friends i think
i could have piped on the white
chocolate to make it a little bit neater
make it a little bit closer to disney
but overall super excited let's move on
to our next treat and maybe that will go
even better
maybe
okay so we've done something mickey i
think it's only fair that we do
something mini so we're gonna make these
minnie mouse halloween cupcakes and the
first thing we're gonna do is make that
little bow at the top so i've melted
some white chocolate here and i am just
going to add a little orange
gel food coloring i think we've got the
right color here so we're going to move
to our mold
i'm just going to pour this over the top
take this offset spatula swipe it to the
side
it looks messy but they're gonna look
great i swear i'm gonna go put this in
the freezer and let it set until we're
ready so next i'm gonna make the batter
for our cupcakes i'm gonna use a box
cake mix so a lot of box cakes mix ask
you to use
water instead of water we're gonna use
whole milk and then mine asks for three
eggs but i'm gonna add an extra egg yolk
adding this extra egg yolk and the milk
is just gonna make the cake taste much
richer and then i'll add oil just mix
this up
all right that looks good to go now
we're gonna put in our cupcake liners i
got some fun little like halloween
ones they're spooky so we'll add that to
our cupcake pan then i'm going to take a
quarter cup of the batter and fill each
one of these halfway up i'm going to go
put this in the oven for 300 for 350
minutes now
my house will be on fire i'm going to go
put this in the oven at 350 degrees
fahrenheit and bake them for about 14
minutes
while that's baking we're gonna make a
buttercream frosting and it's gonna need
a lot of butter two sticks
then we're gonna cream the butter not to
the point where it's airy but it's just
nice and smooth add some vanilla extract
some milk and you gotta have a little
bit of salt in there mix that up again
and now we're gonna start sifting in a
ton of powdered sugar mix that in you
gotta go slow otherwise it's going to be
snow all over your counter all right our
frosting looks good i'll take some of it
and put it in two bowls i'll dye one
orange and one yellow and i am ready to
assemble i think
[Music]
i have a problem
it's so cute i love the chocolate ears i
love the tiny bow and the colors
it's just screaming halloween to me
we'll see what chris thinks at the end
in the meantime let's get started on our
next treat
all right this next treat i'm really
excited about i love monsters inc and i
love mike wazowski
sorry
i had to do it first thing we need to do
for this cake is make our little domes
so i have this cute little mold spray it
with some cooking oil
and then i am using the leftover cake
batter from our cupcakes so nothing goes
to waste for this i'm gonna put this on
a baking sheet in the oven at 350
degrees fahrenheit for about 14 minutes
i'm gonna check it at 10. okay i've got
our cakes they're out of the oven they
are nice and cooled we are gonna make a
white chocolate ganache that's gonna go
over the top we'll add some white
chocolate chips
one can of condensed milk
three tablespoons of butter i'm gonna
put this in the microwave for about 60
to 90 seconds
once you get that out of the microwave
it should be
nice and kind of ribbony so the last
thing we have to do is add some food
coloring all right i think that green
looks good
so now it is time
to pour
looks good
so we're just gonna keep going while
this is still warm
all right so while we let those guys set
i'm gonna dye some buttercream purple
blue and black last thing i have to prep
are candy melts i believe they use a
white candy melt for mike's eye and for
his horns
so i am going to just slice one in half
and that will make his little ears horns
things now it is time to put
one of these bad boys together
[Music]
he looks good he's so cute i love him so
much i only need one good one to show
chris so i'm gonna move on to the last
treat which is really spooky
[Music]
next i'm gonna do the plays and apple
from snow white which i think looks like
the most terrifying snack that they have
served at the parks so i have honey
crisp apples and i've removed the stems
now i'm gonna insert a lollipop stick
inside of them our apples are ready to
go so now we just need to make the candy
i've got about a medium saucepan here
and i have a candy thermometer and then
i'm going to combine some sugar some
water
and some corn syrup bring this up to a
boil and let it keep cooking until it
reaches 300 degrees
we are now at 300 i'm gonna turn the
heat off add a little bit of red food
coloring and stir that in gently i'm
gonna take an apple
and we're just gonna start coating it
okay
that looks like an evil apple i think i
need a backup one or two because you
know i don't know how that design is
gonna go candy apples done now let's put
some poison on them so for the poison
i'm going to keep it really simple and i
got some green candy melts i went for
more of this neon green because that
just seems like
more danger i'm going to put this in the
microwave and melt it in 20 second
intervals until it's nice and smooth
i've transferred my melted candy melts
into a piping bag and
i'm gonna try to do what is the hardest
part of this and that is the poison like
skull face
okay
he looks so angry
it's not great
i feel like this has got to be more
melted
to work
is this the worst
it's pretty bad guys
i gotta restart let's pretend it never
happened right i'm gonna try this again
[Music]
[Laughter]
this looks like a ruffle collar
oh okay i've moved it to a squeeze
bottle and i have added a little bit of
canola oil kelly from our culinary team
recommended it so i'm gonna try this and
see if it looks better
okay i think he looks like the boys and
apple
is he as good as the parks we'll let
chris be the judge i'm pretty happy with
how it turned out like if i went to a
party and saw this guy
i'd want to hang out with whoever made
it you guys want to hang out with me i
can't believe i made it through that
let's go get chris and he's going to
weigh in on what treat is the best
[Music]
whoa these look great thank you but now
you have to choose which one you think
looks the closest to the original and
also taste the best i'm gonna try the
mickey first okay
wow the mickey mommy is really tasty
i don't know if i could eat more than
one of them i'm going to try the mini
cupcake yeah go for it
wow that was the bite definitely tastes
like just a really good traditional
cupcake
all right i'm sorry mike
there wasn't too much ganache i really
liked it okay i really liked it now i'm
gonna bite into this poison apple
wow
that is pretty good it's not as hard to
eat as you think oh i was shocked if i
had to pick my favorite what has
the look of the original and it tastes
really good yes
[Music]
i'm gonna pick the poison apple
wow am
shocked yeah am i the mic to your sully
like are you silly and i'm like nah
you're sully no i'm like
i'm short and i'm pointing yeah
maybe physically i'm bigger than you but
i'm not i'm not able to scare children
as well as you probably
so rude get out
get out
children love me they won't scream when
i'm around what does that mean
yes your mic was out all right i'm done
[Music]
you